if President Biden asked you to take
action with regard to the Trump
investigation what would your reaction
be and meric Garland was on 60 Minutes
and 60 Minutes as I as Megan Kelly
pointed out when I was on her show
yesterday it ain't what it used to be uh
and they asked Merrick Garland if he's
personally involved in taking down
Donald Trump you are not in
communication with the president or any
member of his administration with regard
to the investigation of for president
Trump no I am not if President Biden
asked you to take action with regard to
the Trump investigation what would your
reaction be I am sure that that will not
happen H it's such an idiotic question
do you see how the mainstream media is
so in bed with the Democrats Scott py
there is basically doing the work for
him and then he just has to say you
wouldn't do anything like that like look
into Trump in a weird way or exert any
influence or have any contact with the
Biden Administration to do any weird
stuff about the guy that might run
against your boss for president would
you and Merck's like
no thanks for asking the question dude
like it's just so insane but this is the
way the mainstream media frames things
and we know of course if it was the
other way around they would be framing
it completely oppositely uh so let's go
on to another uh
trial kind of non-trial Department of
Justice what the hell is going on here
situation and of course that involves
Hunter Biden uh this is video uh well
it's from the same interview on 60
Minutes and Scott pelly asked if Merrick
Garland has influenced the Department of
Justice in any way or if the Biden
Administration has influenced him in any
way as it comes to the hunter Biden uh
investigation you're not going to
believe his answer it blew me it just
it's going to blow you out of your chair
watch out hold on you are not
participating in those decisions no Mr
Weiss is making those decisions the
White House is not attempting to
influence those decisions absolutely not
great job Scott Kelly you wouldn't do
that would you you would have no
influence over the he's telling him what
the answer is as if the Attorney General
imagine if the Attorney General was
doing something the Attorney General was
one way or another like leading an
investigation or secretly talking to
Biden or you know secretly talking to
Biden to get rid of trump or secretly
talking to Biden to let Hunter you think
he'd be sit on an interview and be like
Yes actually you know it's so funny you
ask that question because I have been
doing that sort of thing and there is
this asymmetry Injustice I have been
doing it and I just waiting I was just
waiting for somebody to say something to
me it's so idiotically
[Music]
stupid